hi so this video is a little bit
different yes there will be an unboxing
but this is something that is very
special it is custom it is handmade I
saw this Tick Tock and I left a comment
it's a custom iBook with an iPad with a
keyboard and it actually works he had
made this one for Meghan Trainor and I
was like whoa if she doesn't step up let
me know and I was so here for it that it
took me seven days to see in the
comments that he had actually made me
this he was like letting you know that I
made you a custom iBook I just can't
wait to see it I don't know what's in
here though this is a little another
little tiny package it's a huge thank
you just give her films for making this
and sending it to me this is such a fun
little treat he makes a bunch of custom
ones so you can actually buy these so
without further Ado let's get into it
this is
we've got a little USB cable very nicely
packaged oh my goodness we got a little
sticker too look how cute
this is so exciting because I don't even
have an iBook I've got a lot of other
old vintage Macs but and this one is
custom and pink I could not ask for a
better today look how incredible this is
this is definitely going to be a set
piece
foreign
[Music]
ports so this is for the iPad charging
and this is for the internal charging
I charged it all up we've got the
magnets on I love this little detail he
even bought the Condor blue the pink
iJustine cable to go with this you did
say because this is a higher quality
cable and it was a little bit difficult
to get in here no worries we will be
able to do it ah it's so awesome look at
this there it is oh
I mean it can you even like I've
actually speeched speechless okay let's
turn on the keyboard look at this
and the final iBook iPad conversion is
complete I mean this is so creative it
looks so cool and it's pink what there's
a light oh that is a treat oh wow it's
so cool so here is the bottom all custom
pink and I love that this has a little
light on it like that's so freaking cool
one of the things that I always thought
was so interesting about this particular
iBook design is the Apple logo is facing
you but then when you open it up it's
facing down so that's something that
Apple has changed in some of their more
recent devices you'll be sitting at
coffee shops or you're at work and the
Apple logo will actually be right side
up I definitely think that was a smart
move on their part we just need to see
it again I need to show it to you look
at this stuff is it a neat okay we're
not done yet because we have one more
little item
oh my goodness oh this is so cute it's a
little tiny iBook look how cute this is
this is so incredible it's even got like
the little keyboard how perfect
so hyped if you guys want to get more
information about this and all of his
Creations I will put them in the
description below now this needs to find
a perfect place in my office I think I
found just that I can alternate this in
between my old 1984 Mac it's going to
look so so good thank you guys for
watching if you haven't already please
hit subscribe and be sure to like this
video If you enjoyed it and leave me a
comment below and let me know what color
iBook you would want see you guys in the
next video bye
[Music]
thank you